el pasado 8 de enero el canal de
noticias privado bp y cesó sus
operaciones en venezuela luego de que
las autoridades confiscaran sus equipos
y clausurarán los estudios esta acción
dejó sin empleo a 45 personas entre
ellos a la periodista antonieta la roca
lo peor que le puede pasar un periodista
es que lo callen que le pongan un tiro
en la boca que le quiten su micrófono
que le que le pongan dos yeso en cada
mano y le impidan escribir y eso es
precisamente lo que está pasando en
venezuela y no ya ahorita
esto data desde hace mucho tiempo más de
20 años acá en el país el portal de
noticias digital efecto cocuyo también
ha sido blanco de ataque el propio
nicolás maduro le acusa de recibir
dinero de manera ilegal por parte de
instituciones internacionales para
actuar en contra del estado venezolano
para su director a los 1000 y reyes las
autoridades quieren evitar que los
ciudadanos se informen y es además una
difamación una distorsión porque no
están cuestionando el financiamiento
externo sino que además están diciendo
sugiriendo que este financiamiento es
para convertir en informe escenario o
para atacar al gobierno yo creo que es
una de las hipótesis es ir reduciendo
cada día más
las posibilidades de acceso a la
información de los ciudadanos
otra táctica para silenciar los medios
ataques cibernéticos es lo que el
periódico digital tal cual experimento
durante varios días en el mes de enero
futuro bastante complicado
muy difícil porque lo que podemos
esperar es un periodismo independiente
que desaparezca en venezuela que sea una
sola voz la que haya en el país que sea
la voz oficial luego de las últimas
agresiones a los medios de comunicación
en la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos se ha exhortado a las
autoridades venezolanas a propiciar un
entorno libre de hostilidades y a
respetar las libertades una sugerencia
que se le ha hecho al gobierno de
nicolás maduro sin obtener resultados
termine a fernández france24 caracas